Hong Kong is marking the anniversary of
its transfer to China with ceremonies
and protests police used batons and
pepper spray to disperse of crowd of
pro-democracy demonstrators who had
occupied a road near the city's
government complex the activists had
squatted the area because it was near
the site of an official flag raising
ceremony on this day 22 years ago
Britain handed over the korma colony to
mainland China under a deal that would
ensure democratic rights for the city's
people the activists now fear those
rights are being rolled back for more
now from Hong Kong let's cross over to
our correspondent there Phoebe Kong
Phoebe what's happening on the streets
of Hong Kong right now starting point of
the rally happening very soon in the
afternoon and we can see that a my back
political parties and Osito Osito
activist groups they are setting up
booths to like pure on the roots of the
rallies and people started together to
to enter the starting point to
participate in the annual rallies and it
is expected to to take place very
shortly about half an hour later so this
is an annual rally
I wish which is held every year on June
1st and at the same time right now
outside the government headquarter and
lash Co a bunch of protesters some of
them they are now having clashes with
the police and the legislative councilor
because they are trying to break into
the Legislative Council complex by using
something to our nothing into the the
door of the Legislative Council so we
will have love of deaths but obviously
some of the scenes shows on the pictures
are pretty violent we're just seeing
some pictures there on our screen of
those protesters trying to break into
the Legislative Council building it's
obviously quite dramatic at this point
now Hong Kong some though this
demonstration is happening on the
anniversary of honk
reunification with China what are those
demonstrators out there demanding this
is the third rallies I'm happening in
Hong Kong within just a month so we know
that there are two other massive rallies
which over a million people turn out
earlier this month in June so they asked
for the to strap the extradition bill so
today there would be any rally on June
1st they will ask for the same thing to
strap the extradition be entirely and
also to retract the the characterization
of the rioting of the one of the
violence and one of the clashes with the
police and also to release all their
other arrests at protesters which are
suspected to commit to writing crimes
and also on top of that the organizers
of the rally they also openly they call
for a political reform and democratic
reform a game like to the government so
this is a Newton man other than the two
massive rallies earlier in June so we
know that this kind of protest has take
place for a long period of time and some
of the protesters they are using
different kind of methods to to
cooperate amounts and to pressure the
government and we have a spoke to one of
the protesters and so let's have a look
on what they did in the past few weeks
Tinh is a 21 year old student who runs a
supplies stationed outside Hong Kong's
legislature it's been the scene of
frequent demonstrations in recent weeks
it all started online and yielded
real-world results we recruited over a
thousand members on the first day when I
launched the telegram group I also
cooperate with an online forum whenever
I post a message I always received the
first response within a minute these are
the most popular tools for protestors by
using telegram and encrypted messaging
app along with an online discussion
forum people respond to calls for mass
gatherings in order to block roads and
government offices on short notice
Tinh and the other activists also
responds swiftly by delivering
protective gear and mobilizing helpers
to the frontline in the latest wave of
demonstrations the protest leaders
themselves are often just a few of the
many key players we resist any
affiliation with political parties
online platforms are the most neutral
medium because all initiatives are
spontaneous it reflects the will of the
people but not any organisation that's
why people are keen to join the
leaderless movement is led by nobody but
the crowd while hot topics on forums
spawn protest action online polls are
also taken before or during
demonstrations to let protesters make
collective decisions
compared to his own experience than the
umbrella movement tin says the new
tactics can attract supporters beyond
Hong Kong's traditional activist scene
d melody although this movement hasn't
succeeded yet because top leaders of the
government still reject our demands we
learned from the failure of the umbrella
movement and developed new strategies to
pressure the authorities we will
continue to fight until all our goals
are achieved many young protesters liked
in believed that by expanding beyond
conventional rallies a multi-pronged
approach is harder to defeat and even
has a chance of bringing the change they
desire now Phoebe Hong Kong's chief
executive Carrie Lam she has said that
recent protests show the government
needs to spend more time listening to
the people other signs that the
government is now prepared to be more
accommodating with respect to the
protesters demands now what you have
mentioned is Carrie Liam's first
appearance I seen within the or nearly
two weeks that she has disappeared from
the public of sitesell for nearly two
weeks and this is the first time she
showed up again and gave a speech and
during a celebration ceremony of the
handover of Hong Kong to China and what
she said is I just have just like you
have mentioned that she admits that the
extradition bill policy all stirred
controversy and dispute within the
community society but she has mentioned
the thing about the demands of the
protesters regarding whether to withdraw
the extradition bill or not or regarding
whether she will step down now this is
also one of the major the amount of the
protesters so many of them they think
that Carrie Lam speech simply ignored
their demands and they are like studying
and not happy about it and they were
voice their concern to gain on the
streets later in this rally baby thank
you very much
DW is Phoebe Kong there in Hong Kong